amazon just announced its first order of
businesses prepared to take over whole
foods the online giant will close its
13.7 billion dollar deal to acquire
whole foods on monday and then it will
immediately cut prices on the storage
selection of grocery staples like whole
trade bananas farmed salmon and organic
eggs shares of grocery companies
including kroger costco and walmart
plunged after this announcement ooh they
might be worried cbs news financial
contributor mellie hopson is in chicago
good morning melody great to see you
good morning those who remember whole
foods as a hippie co-op in austin texas
must marvel at the size of this deal but
then of course it became the joke whole
paycheck what is amazon's strategy with
this this strategy is very smart they
realize they have a perception problem
and they want this brand to be more
accessible to more people you're right
whole paycheck amazon knows that the
pricing at whole foods has been high as
much as 15 higher than their competition
and they want to deal with this problem
head on very smart move classic amazon
because they've often been willing to
lose short term in order to win long
term so it'll be less profitable in the
short term but to the extent they can
extend the brand and get more scale
that'll drive long-term profits it's
interesting to see the stock prices
yesterday of kroger and walmart take a
hit but it's also worth noting too i
mean whole foods doesn't have the scale
that those other grocery stores have
right
not at all they are really small in
grocery whole foods has about two
percent market share amazon has about
one percent meanwhile walmart is about
20 percent so the gloves are off they
recognize they want to go at this hard
they've done it before i would not count
them out i'd be scared if i were in the
middle not walmart or amazon the biggest
big
brick and mortar retailer the biggest
online retailer but if you're in the
middle of your kroger one of these
mom-and-pop grocery stores of which
there are thousands it's going to get
really tough so melody back to bill's
point a second ago you know it's known
as whole paycheck a shishi poopoo store
so what does amazon want what is a new
look or what's the new brand that they
want for this for whole foods now well
what they want is obviously to extend
the brand to more customers no question
about it they want to take advantage of
whole foods private label business the
365 brand that has over 3000 products
that they can start selling immediately
online they want to take advantage of
this distribution 460 stores and some of
the wealthiest zip codes in america that
has long-term implications for them well
beyond grocery so there are a lot of
synergies here this was an incredibly
smart buy
and it's going to make an incredible
difference it's all part of jeff bezos
plan he's taken over the world thank you
very much melody hobson always good to
see you